the latest daily covert statistics have
just been released and there have been
93 045
new cases of covert 19 recorded in the
last 24 hours another 111 people have
died at reporting a positive covert test
within 28 days that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk
to 147 thousand and 48. well skies and
de brady uh joins us now live with more
on those uh figures so uh ender it
didn't go across a hundred thousand it
has ticked up a bit what are you taking
from the figures that have been released
well kamali it's another record-breaking
day for all the wrong reasons really for
the uk so 93 045
covered positives in the past 24 hours
um staggering numbers really we were
warned earlier in the week
by the chief scientist and the chief
medical officer that we would be getting
towards a hundred thousand cases a day
very very quickly and if you look at the
way the numbers have gone this week they
were hovering around fifty thousand then
they shot up to seventy eight thousand
yesterday eighty 88 000 and today now
just passed 93 000. another 900 people
have gone to hospital in the past 24
hours 111 deaths and really i think all
of the leaders will be looking at these
numbers now and looking at the festive
season and people's plans
and where we go from here now i should
say that at this point we do not have
the vaccination figures for england
included in today's update so if you
take in scotland wales and northern
ireland there have been in terms of
booster jobs 121
439
delivered in the past 24 hours i'm told
the estimate for england will come at 7
pm that's the estimated time that we'll
get booster figures for england so we
will have that news later on um but for
now it is the highest figure in terms of
covered cases ever recorded during this
pandemic 93 045
cases of culvert across the united
kingdom in the past 24 hours